all right psycho yes psycho where'd you
grow up where are you from original
mercedes san fernando valley
tell me about your family growing up um
i don't remember much i left home when i
was 14.
um my mom she was running around with a
lot of hells angels and bikers so
i was raised up around a lot of drug
dealers
you know a lot of bikers
different boyfriends my mom had every
day i didn't know my dad
no um
huh your mom was a biker chick yeah
now the lush at a bar
you know running around with different
bikers you know how that goes how would
you describe your childhood
very rebellious very
just a lot of hatred a lot of anger a
lot of hostility you finished high
school huh you finished high school no i
got a ged on california youth authority
in juvenile hall
i left home when i was 13. so you
stopped going to school at what age now
i stopped going to school about 10.
no i was at home most of the time by
myself my mom worked
and i mean she got home from work with
different boyfriends beating on her
that's all i just
heard arguing with dudes or getting beat
on
no it's a lot of hostility a lot of
anger
a lot of hatreds but i grew up around
you know
a drug started for you at some point oh
yeah yeah um crystal meth
i ended up going to prison for
manufacturing making crystal meth
interstate drug trafficking i did 20
years straight
i did four years in juvenile hall and
california youth authority for drug
dealing
you know um
i was going to prospect for hh but i
went to prison good thing i didn't
already know with life
you know
um
i don't remember a lot most of my most
of my
bringing up when i was a kid was just a
lot of madness you know a lot of chaos
and i grew up real fast
you know i thought drug dealing and all
that was a thing to do you know
i ended up with a lot of time i ended up
you know getting into the skinhead thing
you know i paroled validated gang member
i just got off the gang gang file about
a month ago
you know i'm 53 now i'd be 54 in march
so you were in a mexican gang huh you
were in a mexican gang or no skinhead
gang white gang skin game now
no
a lot of gang
a lot of gangs
you know so how is the skinhead gang
different than the the black gangs of
the mexican gangs
uh
just for your race you know
they're all for the race you know
because the kids make it a little more
a little more racial you know yeah and
in prison it's kind of
a thing now yeah yeah becomes a very
very race oriented yeah
everybody's out in the shoe and out of
the out of the hole so
prison's gonna change you know
not gonna be as peaceful i'm glad i got
out
you know i got my prison number in the
into 88
i've been on parole for almost 10 years
now
i'm on probation but
you have kids
yeah i got a 24 year old daughter
the money i got busted with but put in
for a school and almost almost eight
hundred thousand i paid for her school
and she's now
she's like a year away from being a um
assistant rn
registered nurse at on ucla medical
center right you still have contact with
her yeah you do yeah
no i talk to her like once or twice a
week
she's with my sister over in reno
las vegas
i gave her up to my sister gave my
sister custody
well i couldn't take care of her
so the so the meth
background the the mom that messed my
whole life up you know you must have
some interesting stories yeah
a lot of drug dealing a lot of money
what kind of stuff have you seen huh
tell me a story
i mean i started
i was dealing drugs for about five years
um when i got out of ya i was out for
like about maybe close to five years
i mean i started off with ten dollars
and i ended up getting busted with 52
pounds of crystal meth i taught myself
how to cook
how to make it
you know
thousands and thousands of dollars um
i didn't even talk to people unless it
was about money you know
women
fast cars motorcycles
they took well i got busted they took my
house my motorcycle everything i paroled
homeless
you know and i got busted again when i
got out i was fighting this case
my my mom and dad died my uncle died
grandparents died so
i was on the borderline of being
suicidal you know i ended up
going into a pill mods one in the county
i ended up with an apartment i paid 33 a
month in an apartment right now
you know it's like a section eight over
by six in alvarado
you know i was homeless for about five
years when i got out where are you
staying over by beverly in fairfax
you know where the goodwill is over
there in hollywood yeah in the alley
behind it i was in a tent you know i'm
glad i ain't in the homeless out here in
downtown in macarthur park oh my god
bedlaws killing them
you know
um you have any friends huh do you have
any friends not really man no i
i pick and choose people i talk to
i got a lot older i don't want to catch
time you know everybody's on the fed and
all thing
you know people don't really i believe
in loyalty and integrity still you know
there's a lot of people i don't even
want to talk to you good luck finding
those things good luck finding those
things down here yeah yeah you know this
doesn't exist i don't think anymore
it does but a lot of us don't come out i
don't come out much you know i go from
point a to point b you know do you have
any regrets
yeah i regret jim um
i
wish i could have did a different way
you know
someone went to school or did something
with my life besides at least i got an
apartment but if you had a dad maybe
that might have helped you huh if you
had a dad that might have helped you it
might have helped i had to raise myself
also
i didn't really believe in a dad you
know all the all the people that were
supposed to be a dad were just beating
on my mom you know
i don't believe in hitting women but i
wish i would have had a dad you know
you've been in love before huh have you
been in love before in love
yeah
you know my
the mother of my child ended up taking a
witness stand against me she ended up
being informant for that for the police
i was with her for almost four years she
had my kid got high with me everything
she they called the last witness for the
prosecution and she took the stand
she ended up being a snitch an informant
see i
know it froze
i'll try to try here and there but women
are with games now you know
a lot of these women been through a lot
so
love's a hard word for me
yeah for a lot of me my mom told me she
loved me but she loved heroin more than
me so i don't know i love you
son but you got to find somewhere else
to go so i left when i was almost 14.
it's a month away from being 14.
so your mom was a heroin addict yeah
yeah
are you still using today huh are you
still using today i've used crystal you
know crystal i'm not gonna lie you know
right
what does crystal do for you at this
point you've been using it for a long
time i think it
keeps my mind stable you know
it keeps me from having to feel my own
you know my own emotions and stuff you
know
keep me from having nightmares like
stuff i've done in prison
a lot of stabbings
no it's just how it is in there you know
you don't have to really have a choice
you got two choices in there you know i
try to talk to these kids out here you
know
don't choose the way i went you know
what do you worry about now at this
point in your life what are you afraid
of losing my apartment you know
going back to prison
i won't lose my apartment for nothing
you know
i told anybody you make me lose my
apartment i'm going to go after them man
so you're walking a very straight line
now i'm trying to you know i could
highlight
a deal crystal here and there but you
know
when i have to you know but i'm not
doing the stuff i used to do
nickel and dime [ __ ]
off and on
very seldom you know
other than i don't really
trying not to do [ __ ] you know yeah are
you are you self-destructive do you
think
not as much a little bit not the way i
used to be you used to be much more i
learned how to control it you know
not a time bomb anymore
that's basically what it is
what emotions do you deal with you get
angry or depressed or anxious stress
anxious angry
i see all the money people get and i
want it again but
i live right in 18th street hood you
know
my roommates his brother and all of them
his brother runs 18th street out there
in macarthur park
i could do whatever i want out there but
i see the money that they get
a white person can't you know how it is
over there
we ain't got nothing coming over there
so i'm not stupid you know
like this money i'm gonna take and get
food and clothes you know do some
laundry
no
what has been the hardest part of your
life the lowest point
the lowest part of my life
when i went to prison loss when the
courts took everything i had and gave
gave it all to her because
i put the [ __ ] in my name i should have
put it in somebody else's name so mine
and her name
she got everything
she's under
protective custody you know
i'm not going to do anything to her you
know yeah do you have any good memories
not having a kid you know
i did something at least my money went
to something you know
she still answers my call she don't
really talk she don't say anything but
she'll answer my call she'll say hi and
bye and that's it but at least she
answers my call you know i paid for her
school and so
i did something right you know
other than that i
really can't didn't do anything right
you know
whatever right is you know i wish i
could have did it better you know
wish i would have better role models for
myself you know
yeah you had no role models none
they were all criminals and they all
been imprisoned
gangsters you know i thought that was a
way of life and it ended up being
even my own uncle told me he was in a
shoe he's aryan brother and he told me
you guys are just just me
it's never been about loyalty or
integrity or none of that [ __ ] it's been
about money you guys are money signs if
you ain't making money ain't [ __ ] you
got to go
you know
i pretty much was stripped man i had a
hells angels patch and all that [ __ ] you
know
they put me on a shelf i can't even call
them anymore
when i went to prison you can't they
don't get put no money on your books i
didn't have no no tv in my sale i did my
last nine years of single cell status in
a shoe
no book no tv no nothing i just worked
out meditating you're just isolated
now i live like that
like in my hou in my apartment i sit in
my room like it's myself
my roommate
he knows better when i go in there
he'll say you're busy he'll knock on the
door you know even though it's open
he'll [ __ ]
make himself known you know
i just
i don't like a lot of people crowds
it's really crowded over there you know
i got a teardrop that's for killing one
of the mexicans you know
so a lot of them know what it is but
what would you say is the most important
lesson you've learned in your life
not to make the mistakes i did you know
to think before i act
to think
i used to just act without thinking
no more jumping to conclusions or
assuming anything or stepping on toes
and
taking every second
as a blessing you know
instead of thinking i was god you know
because i had the
money the money is the root of all evil
man
you know
a lot of these people ain't even seen
money or the amount of drugs i did or
had i had garbage i got busted i had
52 pounds of crystals a lot of crystal
a lot i had almost four million dollars
cash on the courtroom table
they took it all
all but the money i had
they let me put send that money give
that money to my to my sister to pay for
my daughter's schooling 740 000 paid for
all her schooling
i paid it all at once
a lot her books she's about a year away
10 months away
if you could have changed one thing
about your the way you grew up what
would you
what would you change
being a better man you know better dad
or better father i wish i would have
been there for my kid
even she said i can't tell her anything
she said
i mean
you're my father but you're not my dad
you know there's a difference
i'm a father because she came from me
but i'm not her dad you know
she thought i was in the military
baby's mama told her
showed her videos and me torturing the
people and all that [ __ ] you know i
thought all that was cool or the thing
to do
now people tell and all that i don't
even care anymore at all
do you feel like a lot of your life was
just spent in the wrong direction yeah
pretty much it was all just a [ __ ]
fantasy
something that
something to control me
i thought it was right
kill the child molester stab a rapist
somebody snitch kill him
i'm not gonna do life no more i'm not
i'm not giving giving them no i mean
they took everything they took my mind
you
i just adapt
i've learned to take every second as a
blessing you
should be into satanism and all that
[ __ ] you know
i give god a chance you know
i don't know if you believe in god but
all right psycho so we
we uh we spoke since that last that
first talk we did
and uh
you told me you'd be willing to tell me
about some of the crazy things you've
been through with some of the stories
you've got to tell
what to
what do you want to share with me
oh you know some of the stupid fights
i've been in for
the dumbest reasons you know um
arguments about
a dollar short or
a day late it's just
a lot of i look back a lot of nonsense
you know a lot of chaos that i called on
myself you know
um because i wanted stuff my way and
it never was my world you know but you
know i just lived like that that's the
wrong path i took you know
i looked back a lot of money i had to
have more and more money i never had
enough money you know
and i would do whatever i step on toes
and i just created
thousands of enemies
uh people just did not
want to even think about me
because i was just i was trying to rake
in money like like uh wall street you
know
i was on a torture thing for a while you
know um people are
especially like bullies and people that
thought they were tough i was like i had
like a thing for him you know
um
i just hate bullies you know
i mean i was when i was younger
my uncle
he almost broke my nose in three places
and i never did it again i'd hate
bullies you know
and you know
i just tried
my homeboy his old lady
her sister for getting in getting her
nose into it
her husband
and my cousin because it was all
that they had their nose all i just
tagged the whole family i said now you
can watch me be on this dude for 72
hours i had his eyelids
i got it out of a book that hitler used
to use it
um
you know dental floss he hold their
eyelids open and shine a light directly
in their eyesight
and
from the lack of sleep in their eyes
they go delirious when you say zip tie
them you mean yeah just kind of like oh
so like this one
like this
and i mean the more you move your arms
the tighter they get
you know to where they were cutting into
this
you know i get
they were cutting into his wrist
you know
and i've seen all this blood i was like
oh man i had to cut them off and they
were already they were stuck in his
flesh you know
and uh
my baby's mom ended up showing my
daughter this video i forgot i videoed
it
and i forgot that it was in my stores
and she had a key to my stores i forgot
all about that she shared with my
daughter this is your real dad you
and i just looked at it last night the
video i i burnt it you know
why and i'm sitting there laughing
i'm looking this way it wasn't funny you
know
you also told me your face used to be
fully tattooed yeah i had a lot of
political shield lightning bolts swazis
my family crest back here um liking
warship you had them removed yeah i
promised my grandparents and
you know i did it for my daughter too i
don't want to
see my face like that you know it's a
lot of regrets on that face
you know i earned them all to
stab people for all of them child
molesters rapists for what you know
i didn't get in and out of it
i got a whole i got extra time i turned
seven years into 20 years with 85
percent
because of raising my hand
um
a lot of they don't even answer my calls
they said we're just
taking your colors from you too much you
know
my answer is i mean you're
if the person's probably get rid of the
problem i just get rid of it
well i guess
what i'm doing after three days a person
wants to leave the planet to get away
from it
i make him stop man
um
scared straight program
um when they when the judge took
everything from me
when he seized all my stuff and i almost
got rico acted
you know that's what they do to like
mafia dawns you know
i'm like i'm a i'm a recording on a
video away from being a regal actor
you know my roommate got me back on the
validation book for another seven years
yesterday because he's he's in 18th
street you know for um
participating in
other races
for money and um
doing too much racketeering all this
[ __ ] you know because people talk you
know
i forget about that you know this
i mean i'm in a mexican area i'm in a
whole nother world the same cycles world
this is their world
and that's what it got me when i let my
roommate trap the house up and
for money
you know i'd rather do that than rob
people you know
like or rip people off or [ __ ] you
know
like this kid he's like a friend of
those naked it makes me sick watching
him smoke this [ __ ] you know
i look back on the [ __ ] i've done
i laughed
on how stupid it was
now that i'm i mean
i'm just snoring i used to slam a whole
gram i have to see spock so i do like
punter union shots of crystal
i learned i taught myself
i got it off of youtube they teach you
how to make dope right on youtube
tell you where to get this [ __ ] tell you
how to get it sent to you
it ain't the same as it used to be him
i'm not trying to do life but
you know taught me a lot you know
a lot of them i have nightmares every
night
i wake myself up
the thoughts are going to run through my
head when i look at some of these dudes
when they make me mad because i flash
quick
there's the real petty stuff that gets
me the maddest because they people think
of running a game a lot of the fee you
know how the females do it they like to
play you push your buttons a lot of them
are into that [ __ ] that irritates you
and i tell them you don't want to
irritate me because
i'm thinking i'm going to tell you what
you now tell them what they're going to
do and they think oh you were right yeah
i was right the man was right you know
i was doing this before a lot of these
people were born and seen ain't [ __ ]
me
it's watered down you know i'm trying to
go back to prison though
you know
because i got i'm institutionalized
they don't even want to arrest me
because they know i'm going to live
better in there i get [ __ ] for free you
know i could sit in a cell and stare on
a wall for 24 hours for for years it
doesn't bother me
you
it doesn't
my mind adapts like that
all right psycho well thank you so much
for sharing your story yeah i wish you
the best of luck yeah with your new
direction now thank you thank you
you